so there's this fantastic Wikipedia list
descriptively titled Wikipedia : unusual
articles
I just remembered as that Wikipedia list
it's a collection of hundreds of
articles about unusual unexpected and
unbelievable subjects no matter what
link you click it's bound to be
interesting for that reason every week
I'm going to click on a new link and
teach you a little bit more about our
amazing world which way should the
toilet-paper hang over or under it's a
point of international contention that's
been touched on by on the family Archie
and The Simpsons and creates rifts and
hundreds of marriages every year to
understand the argument let's look at
the pros for each orientation
we'll start with over perhaps the
greatest objective advantage of this
setup is that it reduces the chance that
your knuckles will run against the wall
this is more than an unpleasant
experience it could transfer dangerous
germs especially if you're in a public
restroom over also makes it easier to
grasp the end since the loose end is
visually distinguished and further away
from the wall hotels cruise ships office
buildings and others can also fold the
toilet paper to indicate that the room
has been cleaned in the over orientation
now for the under orientation this way
arguably has a tidier appearance since
the loose end of toilet paper is more
hidden from view it also makes it more
difficult for toddlers or pets to
unravel the roll if batting at it our V
owners also report that a roll hung
under is less likely to unravel on its
own while driving as a quick side note
I'll bring you a real letter exchange
between a customer and the chairman of
Southwest Airlines herb Keller the
customer wrote last week in my journey
to SFO someone put the toilet paper in
wrong any damn fool knows the papers
come out the bottom of the roll and not
over the top I couldn't figure out how
to correct the error herb responded dear
Jim what the hell were you doing upside
down in our laboratory back to the
debate in general the public prefers
toilet paper hangover most survey is
fine between 60 and 70 percent of
individuals did they put their toilet
paper in the over orientation what's
more interesting however is to
who prefers which orientation older
people tend to have a higher preference
to hang their toilet paper over while
middle-aged people are most likely to
hang their TP under what's most
interesting is to look at the
preferences by socio-economic class
sixty percent of people who are in 50
thousand or more prefer the toilet paper
over while seventy-three percent of
people who were in less than twenty
thousand annually prefer the toilet
paper under when the researcher Barry
Sin rod was asked what this means he
responded I don't know but it's sure
interesting one other research project
concluded that liberals prefer over
while conservatives prefer under now
let's go a little bit deeper therapist
Gilda Karl theorized that the way
someone hangs their toilet paper can
tell you something about their
personality she says if you roll over
you like taking charge crave
organization and are likely to
overachieve
if you roll under your laid-back
dependable and seek relationships with
strong foundations on another note the
butler of Princess Diana Paul Burrell
was asked which method is better and
said of course it should be over if it
worked down it would unravel all over
the floor Royals don't have that problem
though because they have sheets of
tissue which are fanned out into an
attractive display and sit in a box so
that's one way to solve the issue or we
could just look at the patent
oh well that settles it it was made to
hang over come back next week for more
intellectual discussions also click
Subscribe
you